we could hear his high heels clacking to
us is Voldemort I was in second grade
when I picked out the Sorcerer's Stone
it was the first chapter book I had ever
picked up and read there was kind of a
magical story and that Harry Harry
Potter book a wound up on my bookshelf
and I don't know how it got there it was
really like the first thing that got me
to like reading I auditioned for like
one of the like very minor roles you
guys whatever shows up like on Pinterest
or Instagram please tell me it's like
like sex fans yes and hypotony paradigm
of uncertainty oh my god it had been
nearly 10 years since she and Harry
clinging closely to each other had cried
over Ron's body okay
we've already children were ascendant
and Ron is that you've trimmed the fat
it's just like jumps right into it are
you this Christ she just like they wrote
the book I'm having heart like issues
right now I need to know what happened
to Ron it seems a lifetime in past it's
they'd woken at Dana's house that
morning Dana Dana is the least magical
name brand Dana she works at Starbucks
my immortal by xx midnight essence X X
vampire in 9 Y is Harry a vampire why
would Harry be a BAM are they no longer
wizards taking off his clothes so we
could screw he had a six pack a sex pack
and I really hate you know what and
everything and everything and everything
everything
Oh quickie like with no build-up at all
first encounter by Liris malachi
hogwarts didn't mean much
keeping the little he did need was
taking care of I felt how Bert's is a
castle if the castle trying to say it
has sexual needs and that Filch of all
people entity and one time he had dreams
of being an actor richard hogwarts
watched the giant squid approached and
felt apprehension well up in his kitchen
you I love that euphemism allowing the
tentacle inside
we're it brushed against the inner wall
[Music]
I see where this is going
no it's awkward it's about to get
drilled by a giant squid a window I feel
like I need a shower well I feel like I
learned a lot today from these stories I
actually just have more questions than
when I begun who without their demanding
that the squid have sex with the
building of Hogwarts I could have lived
my whole life without that what is great
about fanfiction is that you know it
keeps it alive when JK Rowling did that
big speech in Trafalgar Square at the
last film she said something about how
hopeless will always be that view or
something I really do applaud the fact
that these people took the time to take
something that they obviously love to
and expound upon it use your creativity
do your thing put it out there no I
don't want to read more thank you so
much for your service this should be
turned into a drinking game yeah
honestly how can we incorporate alcohol
into this I could do she talks like that
it's too soon